We're back. Oh my god. iDubbbz apologized, I guess today. Ethan
also said he drops the lawsuit today. That's the big news, okay?
That's the big thing that's happening. We're going to watch some
reactions from around the internet. He completely bent over and
took it. I
dude, it's his life. It's I I'm surprised that people are like,
"Unless you were willing to say like I got a thousand dollars
for you, iDubbbz." And there was like a hundred of you. I don't
know what the [__] you guys talking about. Oh, he
bent over and took it. Yeah.
Who is standing beside him? Who is like, "Yeah, I'll go down
with the ship with you, iDubbbz?" You know when you get to criticize
that guy for taking a knee, it's when you decide that you're
going to go down with him. That's when you get to criticize him
for taking a knee, okay?
Why do people think iDubbbz is responsible to get blood out of
court? Well, he doesn't, and it's not that people think that.
People want him to stand on principle and say like this is wrong
and I'm not going to I'm not going to bow.
And I get that.
But then eventually,
it's like, well, should he just destroy his life? Should he just
like be in ruinous debt
for a long time? Is is that what should happen with iDubbbz?
I don't know. I feel like no, probably not. That's probably not
what we want, right? Am I crazy? That's I feel like that can't
be what we want, guys. I don't know. When you think about it,
do we think that this was just sincere out of nowhere? I know
iDubbbz is saying
and he's kind of coping that way.
But like sincerely, do we do we really think so? We can take
a quick look right now and then I we might look one more time,
Um if you're unfamiliar with the context of any of this, I I'll
give you a brief rundown. I I do think it's important to share
a little bit of my side of the story, but I
I don't want you to take away from the purpose of this video
and that is to apologize to Ethan Klein and his family, um especially
his kids. Basically, Ethan is suing me for having rebroadcasted
a statement made by Destiny on my stream. I did display the very
disgusting comment for 40 minutes and
>> See, this is the thing that gets him is
you know, I didn't want to agree vociferously with Ethan Elow
when they said this, but if there was some way to get him on
defamation, it would be and the reason I think, you know, you'd
end up getting sued and it would at least go
like as far as the the mover wanted to to push it, like the the
plaintiff wanted to push it, is because I think there is some
argument of well, you denounced it, you did you disavowed it
or you said no, but then you leave it up for 40 minutes as a
watermark and that starts to get into weird territory that might
need to be
I It's like I think he loses eventually, but I think it prevents
it from getting dismissed and I think it ends up getting litigated
and so the risk of actually bleeding you out at trial in terms
of money is very real. Or some trial or whatever, just even lengthy
litigation where you just file motions constantly, right?
That's honestly to me the scariest part when you're iDubbz is
I think there's some argument that yeah, he could actually be
sued in a way that's not going to get dismissed very quickly.
I'm just put a skull in the background.
So disrespectful, man. So disrespectful.
So disrespectful. And is suing me for having rebroadcasted a
statement made by Destiny on my stream. I did display the very
disgusting comment for 40 minutes
it was wrong.
It was It was a comment from Destiny and I even said that I don't
agree with it, but it it
it sort of highlights how I knew that it was it was a wrong thing
to put out there into the universe and show people. Um, you know,
regardless of the point I was making, it was wrong. I was angry
and I was like, how do I get this guy to one, not clip me, not
uh mock me and harass me on his live stream and two, this guy's
a bully. I I don't I'm angry. I'm angry that this multi-millionaire
is silencing people and suing people, people who are who have
a much smaller audience than he does and uh you know, can barely
defend themselves. And so, I'm angry. I don't like bullies. So,
I wanted to do something that would uh have an impact and you
know, without checking in with myself of whether or not that
was a right or wrong thing to do. I justified it in my head at
the time. I was like, "Okay, well, it's not my words and uh it's
actually said by a really bad guy, Destiny. Not a fan of that
guy." Anyway, I see what iDubbz is saying and it wrong? Was it
wrong to rebroadcast it? Was it wrong to like I don't think it
was like a unwarranted
escalation on his part in terms of like fighting each other on
the internet. I think it's wrong to sue him for it.
And I think if you wanted to de-escalate, you go from a place
of like, "Hey, I want to de-escalate this. I don't want to keep
having this fight." But man, I
I don't know if I would agree that it's just like wrong to put
that out. I wouldn't I don't think I'd do it myself, I guess,
but I
at least not for like a long period of
I don't know. I'm trying to think of like, do I think this is
wrong? I don't think so.
It's like yeah, it's like a move, but it's it's basically saying
like, "Hey, could would you [__] off? Like [__]
off.
Stop clipping my stream. Stop watching my stream." Like I sort
of get it. Other people do similar [__]
I can see why iDubbz would hand ring about it.
I didn't see it was as wrong until I heard it was 40 minutes.
I mean, I don't know if I Well, I mean, I thought it was more
than 40 minutes before this. I thought it was like 2 hours to
be honest with you. It's a little weird that it was only 40 minutes
now that I'm looking at this, but hey. Have an impact and you
know, without checking in with myself of whether or not that
was a right or wrong thing to do. I justified it in my head at
the time. I was like, "Okay, well, it's not my words and uh it's
actually said by a really bad guy, Destiny. Not a fan of that
guy." It's very clear that it was never the right thing to do.
Uh it was a a comment about Ethan and his children and it was
it was disgusting. I said at the time in the stream that I don't
agree with it, um but still sharing it and broadcasting it to
people for 40 minutes, that was an irresponsible and reckless
thing to do. Uh especially >> Maybe you just cut Maybe
you just cut the part where
you crop so you don't have the part about the kids in there for
iDubbbz, I >> for parents. Like there are there are many
parents with kids out there who do not want to see that [__]
and it's painful, and I'm sure it
>> I What I don't like here is
How do I put this? I I don't like dragging somebody's kids into
something or dragging third parties into something. Do you know
what I mean? I'm personally against that, but
uh man, there's like a lot of different things going on for me
here, cuz I don't like the way that Ethan has framed this as
his him defending his kids. I've never seen it that way. I don't
think it has anything to do with that, right? I don't think his
kids were put in danger by iDubbbz' statement, by iDubbbz re-broadcasting
that statement. I just don't think so.
I also think Ethan did a lot of lying in terms of why he was
angry at Ian to begin with, like talking about how Ian supported
the CPS call or something, which never happened. So, it's weird.
Like I Maybe I could believe this for Ian. Maybe.
I don't know. It feels like this is all How do I explain it?
It's like it's uh kabuki theater trying to make it seem like,
"Well, iDubbbz is just doing this for himself. It has nothing
to do with Ethan, you know, offering to drop the lawsuit." And
I just see it as the precise opposite. I see it as somebody reached
out and said, "Hey, if you just do another apology, we'll drop
the lawsuit. We don't want to actually do Do you know what I
mean? That's what I think happened, and I think they're trying
to give the opposite impression. So, it just feels weird and
dissonant in it. Like there's a dissonance here for me. I think
that's what's happening, right? As in they want to make it seem
like it it I'm guessing it was like possibly even a part of an
agreement. Like we're going to make it seem like this isn't this
isn't just us doing this, right? But, it is. It is just them.
It is just them coming to an agreement that it'll be dropped
if there's just some small apology, so. >> It was extremely
painful for Ethan and Ela to read that and have it pop up again
and again and again. And just because it's coming from a piece
of guy and I'm I'm showing it to people like, "Look what this
piece of said." It's wrong. It's wrong to do and I didn't, you
know,
I didn't come to this overnight, right? Like, I'm
to be frank, I'm angry. I do not like Ethan. I think he's doing
a lot of damage to people online uh and it it it
it changed the way that I was thinking about it. I didn't think
about it uh I you know, I didn't ground myself. I didn't think
about, "Oh, like who is who is actually being affected in this
instance?" And Ethan's family and his kids are being affected,
you know? I I just because I don't like Ethan, I think it's wrong
to find uh an attack vector that is his kids. It's It's It's
foul. It's not okay. >> He's He's maintaining the thing
He It's very similar to the first apology, which is strange to
me. There was an apology that came after the original cease and
desist, right? That's the timeline here. Where do I see it as
different? Because I remember the previous apology, I want to
say Idubbbz said something very similar. Like, "I feel like this
wasn't who I am and I shouldn't have done this and it was wrong
to do,
but I wasn't like saying it myself. It was not my opinion." I
didn't say anything about it. It feels like
another like the same apology over again. I would like to see
maybe a comparison between the two. >> I think it was wrong
to do what I did using the Destiny screenshot as a cudgel to
make my point. I didn't need to use the Destiny screenshot to
make my point. I There's a There's a million other ways I could
have done it, but I didn't and I I regret that I didn't and I
regret that I ever put that screenshot on my live stream. You
know, that's the main reason why I feel like I I do need for
myself, for my soul, to own up to this and acknowledge that I
went too far. It wasn't okay. Ethan and Ela and their family
do not deserve that. At the end of the day, whatever happens
with the lawsuit is what it is. For for myself, I needed to make
it known on the internet that what I did >> This totally
isn't about the lawsuit, >> was wrong and I don't want
to be that person. I don't want to behave that way. I want to
make content that I'm proud of. I I don't want to give in to
a a harassment back and forth online. I want to put my energy
into making content that I can be proud of and that I'm not going
to be ashamed of uh because I, you know, I lost the plot. I I
want to stay focused. I want to check in with myself and know
what it is I want to be and what I want to do and what message
I want to spread.
And this isn't a message I want to spread. So, I'm sorry to Ethan
and Ela and your family. You guys didn't deserve that. I'm going
to uh think about all of this a lot more, I'm sure. Um but for
now, I really do want to just uh get back to making the content
that I want to make. Having said all that, I wish everyone the
best. I, you know, I genuinely want to see a better world and
I do not want to be a contributor to what makes it terrible.
So,
so long.
>> Uh man, like okay, little bit I man, little bit believable
that I I think he does actually like this is sort of in
right? That he feels bad about this. It's sort of in character
for him. But,
and I don't mind him apologizing if he could get out of it. But,
what I don't understand is how this is different from the first
apology cuz it feels very very very similar. Maybe
maybe it's the thing about how Ethan and Ela don't deserve that.
Hold on. Let me Let me pull up the original apology. We'll We'll
give that a gander as well
before we start getting into some of the stuff around these apologies,
okay? So, here's the first apology right here. >> I think
one of the things that sort of woke me up a little bit is like,
"Okay, wait a minute. I need to take a step back." It's the the
Destiny thing about Ethan and his kids. That was one of those
where I was like, "Oh man, I think I I stepped too far out with
this one." Where it's like I'm I We know the reason that I, you
know, uh showed you guys the the comments
>> Man, it is not >> about Ethan and his kids. It's
because it's like >> This was forced by C&D, too, right?
Well, here's the thing. I think the apology that he's giving,
I want to say that they seem or feel very, very, very similar
to me.
I think the only thing that's changed, really tangibly, is the
Moist Critical video and the commentary after. You know what
I mean? I think that is the tangible change in the playing field
here, and Ethan feels like he can no longer culturally like handle
filing this lawsuit. And so, to me, what it's so hard for me
to get away from this because I'm of like two minds. I don't
want to hold it against Ethan that he made the right decision,
and yet I feel like he did this original cease and desist, items
apologized that he shouldn't have done it, and then after that,
Ethan still kept going. And that's particularly psychotic to
me. I don't know how to I don't know how to drop this off now.
>> Destiny's a He's a piece of and he's >> I like
I I don't know how to let go of that cuz that felt so weird.
I don't know how to >> Clearly, he has bad intentions,
but he's going easy on this guy, not going on not going easy
on Denims Frogan, Casey Tron,
many others, right? And that that was my reason for showing it,
but I was like, you know, after reflecting a little bit more,
I'm like, "Ugh, I do not want to roll around this pig [__]
It's not within my principles
to put that online. I don't want to spread that because it's
just it's just negative and it's not true. I don't believe it.
It didn't feel right." So, that's why I'm like, you know, trying
to take a step back from the Scorch Lagoon stuff and not roll
around in the pig
I'm I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to Ethan and Ethan's family for uh putting that nasty
Destiny comment out there. I felt like it was >> Man, it's
hitting like all of the same points, right? This isn't This is
like the same apology.
This is like the exact same apology. There's like maybe a little
more hand-wringing in the second one about how, "Oh, well,
I'm sorry to Ela and Ethan and their family didn't deserve that
and you should never bring people's There's like a little bit
more of that in the second apology, but otherwise, it's basically
the same. >> do based on the point I was making, but it
gross [__] shouldn't be spread like
It's hard, man. It's hard because they catch [__]
all the time and it's like, "How do I engage?"
Well, I have to have to be nasty back. It's tough. It's tough.
From what I've seen, it seems like their podcast has slowed down
with the um specific harassment
publicized
intentional harassment against Anisa and
I guess what they do in their free time is uh is up to them,
but I need to move on. I need to do other [__] I
understand how hard it is to get attention online when you're
not relying on kind of the easy and the easy [__]
is like rolling around in drama.
>> That's that's crazy how similar these two apologies
are.
The biggest difference is naming Ela. Uh
I I mean the biggest difference is just the timing that Ethan
doesn't feel like Ethan's been basically called out by a bunch
of people since this one. Since he got this one and then he decided
to talk about it and not drop the lawsuit after
The biggest difference is he's gotten criticized by people.
I feel like now it's just it's not sentiment. It wasn't about
sentiment the first time. It was about like window dressing.
It was about a couple of these different pieces of window dressing.
That's all it was actually about. You know what I mean? Like
oh you need to post it somewhere where it's more visible. Oh
you need to like really really go into how you [__]
over my family and stuff.
But it's like the sentiment, the actual statement is more or
less the exact same. It's it's yeah it's basically the exact
same.
Goofy. Goofy stuff.
Interesting. Man, I
You want to know what I don't like about this? I don't like that
iDubbbz is
And maybe this is the thing I actually dislike the most is he's
sort of leaning
almost like what
He's leaning into
what Ethan was saying even though that doesn't make sense in
my opinion. Like he is basically saying like I'm sorry for doing
this to your kids. Well he didn't do anything to his kids. I'm
I'm sorry. You didn't put his kids at risk. You didn't
Ethan won't have to
There'll be no mea culpa for all the
Zero mea culpa for all the lying. All the lying going to be totally
fine, going to be totally let go.
Ah very frustrating, man. Yeah. I I know I don't want I don't
want Ian to do anything different. Ian should take the easy trapdoor
out.
Obviously, right?
But I think the sad thing for me is
Does this actually help Ethan's image? Honestly, this feels
more sad to me than anything.
For Ethan. Like Ethan
I can't imagine how Ethan thinks that this was a good way to
approach this. Like like that he needed to extract the second
apology to feel like he won and that was more important than
de-escalating. That was more important than anything else was
getting the apology, right? Like it's just so sad. It's so petty.
It's so small.
I don't know what else to say about it. It's It's It makes me
feel bad for him.
honest to God. Like it just makes me feel bad. I think if he
had approached this in a way where he was like, "No, no, no,
no, like I we need to both apologize to each other." That's what
I would have like to see. Is Ethan saying I was not totally Ethan
basically doing some kind of me a couple like I said where he
says, "I actually [__] up, too and I I apologize
for pushing it to that place." The one-sided thing just feels
very petty to me, but again, I I guess Like I'm not saying apologize
for being upset about the statement, either. I'm saying apologize
like A logging the guy's content to the point that he felt he
had to do that, right? In a way that you also don't like being
done to you. You know what I'm
There's this whole thing that happens with the snark stuff where
we decide apparently. Apparently this is a normal
Okay, something bad happened to Ethan. Now, no matter what someone
else's culpability is for that bad thing no matter what, it's
I'm going to treat you like you did the bad thing directly.
Right? And for Ethan, there's like a million different people
who have this distributed like
cause like causality relationship with maybe something bad happening
to him.
Like a bunch of haters all over the internet and he's like he's
trying to basically create a like a focus like an idol. He's
trying to create like a simulacrum for that entire group out
of one person and then he's going to destroy that one person.
And it's just this process repeating, and I think he thinks that
eventually people will stop doing that. But it doesn't work.
It won't work. It like makes you look worse every time.
He's still got the Noe Samson lawsuit going, which I don't think
it's going to go anywhere. Yeah, I don't I really just it feels
sad for Ethan, and I don't think he's learned very much, and
I don't think he is
going to stop. So, boy, oh boy. I don't mean to bring down the
mood or anything, but it's just kind of sad. I just feel I feel
genuinely bad for the guy.
I I've seen a lot of people going hard on Ian for not
seen people going hard on Ian for not standing up and continuing
on with his litigation, for doing this so that he would get it
dropped. And I can't get behind that. I'm sorry.
I think there's no way, and I don't have any I don't have any
[clears throat] hope that, you know, if some other small creators
sued, that they'll really be supported. Like, I don't think Frogan
got basically anything in her GoFundMe.
I really don't. I think Frogan got like nothing, to be honest
with you.
AC, I don't think she got very much support. I don't think um
Like, Denims has earned her support, basically, right? I just
I
I think you can judge Ian if you're willing to take the same
risk that he would have going through this, right?
Then you can judge him. But, it's funny cuz I do see some people
calling him out and saying like, you're such a for
And I do expect some of those people to
And that's the that's the other thing about this, like forcing
these apologies out. I don't think you ever get to a place where
where the snarkers, quote unquote, or the people who are associated
with snark, or the people who just watch your content and don't
like you anymore, which I guess we also call snarkers,
those people are going to escalate off of stuff like this, and
so I don't see where it slows down, but yeah, believe how many
drones defended defend the Noe Samson in Always, he said Ethan
supported a genocide. Yeah, that's an opinion bro. Well, it is
an opinion and it's an opinion that he's justified and it's a
political opinion. It's a political opinion that anybody upholding
like Zionism in general supports the genocide which is actually
starting to become like a more mainstream opinion.
So it's like it's a like a political view with a lot of people
behind it.
It's totally insane to sue somebody over it but whatever.
With all of that being said,
oh boy oh boy it might be time to get into some reactions. Okay,
we're going to go through quite a few. Here we got Clipping Wings
grabbed the a mic from PA clip here. Mike from PA is annoyed
with Idubz new apology to Ethan Klein. You're showing his hypocrisy.
He doesn't care about defamation. He doesn't care about copyright.
He cares about attacking the enemies of Israel and the friends
of Hasan [__]
I don't think this is true.
I don't think this is true. I think he it happens to be
that the enemies of Israel and friends of Hasan [__]
overlap with people who dislike Ethan Klein for various reasons.
I don't think these are the distinguishing factors. I think it's
anyone Ethan sees as like basically one of his haters online.
And it happens to overlap with these things and uh probably there
is some some big thing with Hasan where he actually just hates
Hasan and blames Hasan for a lot of his problems. Okay? But I
I don't think it's just these things. What's the I don't like
Ethan. I think it's wrong to find an attack vector that is his
kids. It's it's Okay, you're not attacking him for like you like
I get that he's doing an apology because
Oh, Mike's going to say the same thing. You're like reinforcing
his delusions about what was happening here, right? Which feels
weird and feels totally required for Idubz to get out of the
lawsuit. So I get it, right? I get it. Unfortunately, this is
exactly what Ethan would require for Idubz to get out of it.
So unlucky. >> Maybe he feels bad but you weren't doing
an attack vector on Ethan Klein's kids. You weren't.
You weren't.
You were showing his hypocrisy. He doesn't care about defamation.
He doesn't care about copyright. He cares about attacking the
enemies of Israel and the friends of Hassan [__]
That's what it's about. It's not about You know what I was legitimately
thinking that you were saying that? You were saying, "Notice
how he doesn't care about defamation when it comes from a pro-Israel
source." Notice how he doesn't give a about defamation when it
comes from Destiny. And Destiny giggled when he reacted to Ethan
Klein talking about it because he knows it's true. Does anybody
have a link to that? Somebody find me a link of Destiny reacting
to Ethan saying they didn't have any of this feud with Destiny
>> Okay. All right. Well, there's that one and then there's
one more. I got one more clip of the mic from PA. Reaction.
>> Apparently Ethan dropped the lawsuit. There was a comment
from the official H3H3 username on Ethan's video.
I think they were already planning on dropping it after they
got pushback from uh Moist Critical. >> Yeah, I think that's
the biggest change here, obviously. It's the pushback from
>> Hi Ian, I appreciate the thoughtful apology. It means
a lot. I've instructed my attorneys to drop the lawsuits
>> Oh, I forgot to go and grab the obviously the top comment
here, right? That H3H3 Productions, this is Ethan's main account.
Instructed my lawyer attorneys to drop the lawsuit entirely.
>> Again, you know, my general
>> Again, you know, my general feeling is good for them.
Good for them.
Good for them. The only reason he's dropping it is cuz he got
pushback from Moist Critical.
And then have we read this? We read this. Uh please trust that
what is being done is what feels right.
All right, well, if it works, it works.
>> Oh, there is a law in Canada, by the way. People are
saying that Idubbbz shouldn't say this because his lawyer shouldn't
should tell him not to. In
I believe any apology you make cannot be used against you in
a court of If you apologize for something,
>> if that That's And you when you think about it, that
fits into the international Canadian identity so well. Canadians
known for apologizing for nothing. You cannot be sued. You cannot
help be held responsible for an apology.
It is not an admission of guilt.
It's called the apology act. I That listen, that's the way it
is, man. You You apologize to somebody, you can't be sued for
it. Is it sorry law? Yeah, it's the apology act. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
So, you are allowed to apologize for something. You're allowed
to do that. Is this a joke? This is very real. I am not joking.
Hold on. I'm definitely not
Good stuff. And then we read this We read this uh Please trust
that what is being done is what feels right.
All right. Well, if it works, it works. It works, it works.
I'm happy for them. So, the only people that are
Okay. Yeah, I I do think I wish iDubbbz didn't have to reinforce
like the delusions. That feels weird to me. That feels wrong
to me.
But other than that, it's like I don't really have any problem
with him apologizing. Some people got really on him. Some people
were very upset about
See, can I grab a Yeah, there's like a thread here. Hold on.
There's a thread.
iDubbbz So, this is a response to the Octweet. iDubbbz is full
stop going to get false accusations from Anisa when she gets
bored and nobody's going to defend him because he kind of deserves
Weird response.
Very weird comment to me. Okay, very odd comment. Oh, we got
a Keemstar We got a Keemstar comment. Big likes on this one.
No hate for iDubbbz for doing what he needs to to avoid financial
hardship, but it's unfortunate that Ethan Klein is demonstrating
for everybody that abusing legal and support systems to bully
your enemies into silence is simply a winning tactic that there
are few defenses for.
I would like this to I would like people to like basically
kind of close ranks on stuff like this. It sucks that it was
iDubbbz. It sucks that there are people that get identified and
turned into like oh, well, actually any act against you is correct.
It's okay.
And really, for iDubbz,
like the thing to me is
I've heard this lie over and over and over again that iDubbz
justifies the CPS call or iDubbz celebrated the CPS call to Ethan's
house.
And I I believe both of those are just outright lies. And so
it's weird that you have to lie about this guy to get his reputation
low enough to your community so that you can do whatever attacks
you want to on him, right?
It just feels bizarre to me that that whole process of dehumanizing
iDubbz to Ethan's community so that you can go and sue him and
your community totally supports you.
I'm in the middle of that transformation, unfortunately. Hey,
it's almost like I see that getting blamed for all these things
that actually there's just no reasonable way you could actually
say this.
There's no reasonable way you can blame me for the things that
are happening.